adele opens up in a rare no-holds-barred
interview and she's talking all things
divorce parenthood and new love
absolutely the grammy winner gets candid
in her interview with both british and
american vogue talking about the end of
her marriage to simon kaneki the two
tied the knot in 2018 split in 2019 and
finalized their divorce earlier this
year quote it just wasn't right for me
anymore i didn't want to end up like a
lot of other people i knew it wasn't
miserable miserable but i would have
been miserable had i not put myself
first and she says she recorded a lot of
her upcoming album rumored to be called
30 for their nine-year-old son angelo
the hello singer tells the mag that
angelo had a lot of questions that she
doesn't have answers for questions like
quote why can't you still live together
adele says hopefully someday this album
will help to give him some clarity quote
i just felt like i wanted to explain to
him through this record when he's in his
20s or 30s who i am and why i
voluntarily chose to dismantle his
entire life in the pursuit of my own
happiness it made him really unhappy
sometimes and that's a real wound for me
that i don't know if i'll ever be able
to heal it's an amazing thing to show my
son you know and i'm raising him to
respect women and he knows i'm a
powerful force he feels it just at home
let alone you know when he comes to work
with me and he comes everywhere the 33
year old mom of one says she also put
some songs on the album to show angelo
how she expects him to treat his future
partner quote after going through a
divorce my requirements are sky high
there's a very big pair of shoes to fill
adele says one of the big questions she
personally faced following the split was
how she and her ex would break apart
their lives and she said the answer is
they aren't quote in the end i was like
we're not going to you bought the house
opposite my house nothing changes for
angelo and she says they're still super
close quote i trust him with my life i
definitely chose the perfect person to
have my child with it's been a complete
whirlwind now adele confirms she's
dating sports agent rich paul she tells
the mag they are quote very happy adding
it feels like it's consistent and
considerate enough that i don't care who
knows he's great he's so [ __ ] funny
he's so smart you know of course earlier
this week adele teased her new single
easy on me
the track will be her first new song in
nearly five years and it's set to drop
on october 15th she says the track is
the first one she wrote for the album
and it's all about the end of her
marriage quote i didn't write anything
else for six months after because i was
like okay well i've said it all
[Music]
you